pas j'ai trop souffert tous ces jeux
rageant là ça m'a flingué le cerveau
j'ai plus envie de vivre vous comprenez
et le marteau a fait déborder le
chaudron les amis après tant d'heures de
souffrance a passé sur ces [ __ ] de
jeux vidéo challengeant aujourd'hui j'ai
besoin d'un peu de calme un peu de repos
du coup on va jouer au jeu le plus
facile du monde c'est comme ça qu'ils
appellent en plus encombré ya un petit
chat pour nous indiquer que ses gentils
bienveillant tout ça à tanger sfax pas
du mito et que c'est vraiment j'ai
facilement 6-1 jura gens là c'est là que
je vais péter un câble je suis quizy
caté en raison d'une condition
malheureuse je ne peux pas supporter la
vue une question difficile mais que ça
m'arrange énormément comme moi tu auras
neuf vies et seulement 9 atteint mais
qui a une histoire de vie c'est que
c'est pas facile avec qu'elle maintient
touita cuillère la main gauche sous la
main droite où aucune des deux dans le
cas où tu as subi un très grave accident
tu dirais aucune des deux mais
normalement c'est la main gauche
les gens riches long et les gens pauvres
l'ont aussi c'est très très connu
malheureusement pour toi et c'est rien
voici mon chien bleu de quelle couleur
est mon chien battant mais c'est trop
connu ça c'est avec un cheval même la
langue française qu'on a fait cette
femme quelle est la couleur du cheval
blanc d'henri iv
et ben si tu mets vert tu te trompe pas
ce qui les bleus attend 12 secondes ça
normalement au le batave est plus fiable
mais bac c'est pas du tout simple c'est
incroyable lequel sont les états unis au
quai jean moulin de quel état il s'agit
mais mec cdo
je suis français ce matin le nouveau
mexique ida au rhode island où le texas
la forme laisse penser d une vague une
vague l inverse du texas étonné que le
texas est très sec
c'est peut-être la réaction qu'il faut
avoir dans le cadre il veut nous induire
en erreur mais rhodes island part d'une
aiguille il est forcément autour et tout
cela pour être la bonne réponse c'est
bien sur l'île
combien de coupe il y at-il dans un car
un quart de litre à quart de litre c'est
une demi pinte une demi pinte
qu'est ce que je raconte là ok une
demi-tasse ses douze centilitres donc de
tasser 206 une faute deux skiffs et 24
centimes ce qui donne un cadre de l'its
donc dans un cas
combien de karuïa t-il dans un gallon
alors ça oui parce qu aux us on parle en
galons pour les sources 1 gallon ça fait
3785 millilitres d'eau consent-il tafer
378 combien font d'eux plus de +7 - 7 de
plus de quatre points 7/11 -7 4 go
combien de côté un square at il eu un
d'anglais de merde un carré ta tête
quand tu réalises que square peut dire
car et il y en a quatre
mais je suis content mais je suis
content ça me fait du bien combien de
côté possède un rectangle
moi ça va aussi tu vas pas nous la faire
foi oui combien de pâtes un chien
possède 4 si tu prends la moitié du wave
voiture mon cas je suis sérieux à l'âge
de me concentrer si tu coupes la moitié
de la jambe d'une araignée parce que tu
es cruel combien de jambes va-t-il
rester à l'araignée à ce moment précis
je ne me rends pas compte de la gravité
de mon erreur j'ai en fait mal gratuits
d'annoncés if you take the spiders lives
of ne veut pas dire si tu retires la
moitié d'une jambe d'une araignée mais
veut dire si tu retires la moitié des
gens d'une araignée
la suite vous la connaissez combien y
at-il de saison dans une année à
on est bien combien de doigts y at il
sur une main humaine
5 à combien de questions as-tu répondu
atteinte en fausse conscience vous
présentait il y avait l'histoire des
pays y avait l'histoire de l'araignée il
avait l'histoire du calcul est l
histoire du nombre de saisons dans une
année juste deux ou trois autres je
dirais 10 est ce qu'une grenouille cogne
sont derrière par terre quand elle saute
[Musique]
baba mon nom j'ai perdu est ce que c'est
le jeu puissantes du monde
oui ok on est bien jusque là tout va
bien est ce que l'os est en train de
faire ses besoins dans les bois se
trouve là il est juste assis sur un
tabouret mecque et ils attendent le bus
et le pq est là se trouve la même pas vu
c'est peut-être juste des gens frustrés
combien pq sur la branche parce qu'ils
voulaient voir un cadavre comme logan
paul pour le film est alors non [ __ ]
mais moi je suis trop habitués à notre
quiz est tous fautifs et incombaient à
de lapin
[Musique]
j'ai pris mon temps pour compter ce
temps là là je le prends même pas pour
méditer tous les jours ou pour faire le
point sur ma situation familiale
appuyez sur le bouton joue peu avec mena
qu'est-ce que tu mets dans un toaster du
pain harris mais [ __ ] mais tu es là
quand je prends le petit déj bah moi au
morpion alors là mec t'as pas de change
pas sa vision de philo à faire ça pour
gagner c'est très simple j'ai gagné
je vais faire comme les mecs dans la
forêt pour exprimer mon mécontentement
je vais mettre un pq calais tu as ça ça
représente du gel là où il fait très
froid c'est en ontario
ce raisonnement est nuls à chier jeu de
mots la couleur du soleil tôt le matin
c'est orange et en plus à un mot
transparente c'est orange c'est comme le
soir tard ne me dites pas que c'est faux
[Musique]
ok vous venez d'assister qui coûte cher
sa colère v ça devait me faire du bien
voici mon chien bleu de quelle couleur
est mon chien mais attends ils changent
de couleur dès que je vais sur une
couleur ah c'était ça le piège du coup
les verts yes est ce que cette lune est
faite de fromage oui a priori tu as 5
kendy barre dans un bol qui en retire 3
combien de kenzy barre il te reste ça
dépend tout est une question de point de
vue alors là il ya débat est-ce que le
bol t'appartient ou pas s'il bolt
appartient et le reste dans le vol donc
il en reste deux mais si le vol n'est
pas à toi ça veut dire que c'est toi
qu'on a pris 3 pour les mettre dehors
donc les trois sont à toi on va partir
du principe que bolton où est ben voilà
oh [ __ ] talma siens combien on a 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 j'ai passé huit heures
sur cette question mais je vais avoir
bon ça je vous le dis braid brède
ok il ya un petit avion qui s'est crashé
et chaque personne est mort combien de
personnes avons survécu tout le monde
parce que personne n'était à bord
ah c'est ça la blague on en est là dans
ce jeu c'est bien
alors assez un pan du hockey il manque
une jambe comme l'araignée d'ailleurs
alors uni manque une demi jambes ou une
jambe obs que je ne me rends pas compte
que cette blague ne marche pas du tout
car je ne me rends toujours pas compte
que j'avais mal traduit l'énoncé je suis
un vrai looser castle games ait eu
marges dans un restaurant dans la pièce
il y a dix personnes qui ont 21 ans
trois personnes qui ont 26 107 personnes
qui ont 29 ans et neuf personnes qui ont
31 ans y en a dix sept qui sont des
garçons combien de gens ya dans le
restaurant ok il attire notre attention
sur des détails alors que juste retenir
le clip de base à savoir combien je vaux
rien si l'on connaît bien
homme est témoin des gifles voilà et
m'explique pas la blague voilà comme ça
je suis sûr d'avoir fou quand je
recommence trouve une partie du corps
qui peut se faire de la même manière à
l'endroit et à l'envers bas à coude
coutts a fait et donc j'y mets un coup
de douk hockey what is the number
between moinel tous et un nombre décimal
ouais mais vu que c'est en anglais c'est
pas vrai non mais j'en ai marre premier
comme si le car on avait dit que ta mère
la slip
alice à 14 sur le saïga sablon la fin
soit une question quel âge à alice et
ben voila voila tiens ton cou
quel est ton nom le cas royal a comme
une question as-tu répondu à 9 ses
marques elle a en fait on à gauche quel
pays est le plus grand l'angleterre où
les unes des états unis les états unis
doit juste une petite une chute de
cheval est ce que tu es sûr mais c'est
quoi cette question est non
ah ah ah bah oui c'est la bonne réponse
je n'étais pas sûr de la réponse c'est
bien la décimale bah oui c'est incorrect
parce que tu es un jeu anglais était
raciste nombre décimal décimales number
à [ __ ] je valide les charges de
l'impasse et a marché regarde cette
scène tu ne pourra la voir qu'une fois
observe bien ça va être en tous cas en
avoir c'est sur place est ok
oui
[Musique]
jaune jaune tiens ta grosse merde j'ai
regardé que ça leur passe qu'il est tard
et que j'ai faim quelle était la couleur
du sofa s'étaient vus restée violet yes
haye
c'était la maison qui crise qui crissent
l'otan yes we type btr quatre heures
d'orgues mec j'ai les deux on va dire un
chat the world swing in the same farhad
mba 3m cède 1,9 million je n'en peux
plus c'en est trop pour moi c'est ça le
début 2018 s'est joué à un jeu facile
qui emmène les 20 jeux faciles
après tant d'efforts tant d'heures
passées à se battre pour passer les jeux
les plus durs
ben non messieurs ça se passera pas
comme ça s'il ya bien un truc que j'ai
appris dans la vie c'est qu'il faut
persévérer pour y arriver alors on va
persévérer
[Musique]
jean qu'elle dormait tôt
vous savez
et ça
et mme l
d
oubliez tout ce que je vais dire on s'en
bat les couilles persévérer jamais dans
la vie rosea soyons des losers je pense
que c'était bien aller l'aca luxe
ça
[Musique]